hey guys it's Charlie this is gonna be
my Walking Dead episode 1 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet we're just gonna go through the
comic book Easter eggs and talk about
how we got kicked in the nuts
twice most of you were probably thinking
about death predictions going into the
episode like when we got through the
second commercial break and we still
hadn't found out I just had the horrific
thought that they were gonna make us
wait till the end of the episode to
actually find out the way they broke it
up with Rick's flashbacks most of the
episode was told from Rick's perspective
as he was experiencing all this and I
love the idea of an episode that just
told from the perspective of Rick and
negan but then they went back to the
more traditional format after they
finally revealed that it was Glenn and
Abraham and they were really like the
safe picks so let's just do top 10 WTF
and comic book Easter eggs they did a
lot of comic book stuff and I'll explain
like the big change number 10 negan
arrives issue 100 in the comics the
thing is is that episode 100 of The
Walking Dead will be the first episode
of season 8 and they renewed the series
for season 8 last week it may have even
been two weeks ago so before they ever
dropped an episode of season 7 they've
renewed it for a full season aid there
are people inside AMC that want Walking
Dead to go on forever I mean it makes
more money than almost any other TV show
in the history of the planet so of
course they want to keep it going as
long as possible but from a storytelling
perspective Robert Kirkman has said that
there's so much more for him to tell in
the comics and just to give you an idea
for where they're at so I said negan
debuted during issue 100 of the comics
they're on issue number 159 now so if
they're already way past that and
Kirkman is saying the comics have a lot
more story left to tell then there's so
much more that they could do on the TV
show they could probably get to season
10 if they really wanted to pretty easy
so negan debuts issue 100 as a way to
tell the fans hey you know this is issue
100 we've been doing the comic for a
long time please don't stop reading
because there's still so much left to
come and he just dropped negan the TV
shows version of that scene which was
basically like the finale from last
season in this episode combined you kind
of to combine those two episodes they
were pretty faithful to most of the
comic book moments and probably the
biggest change was the Abraham kill
number nine though teasing cutting off
Riggs hand they did this for most of the
episode the way he asked Rick do you
have a right hand man the way he played
with Rick's axe the way the camera
filmed it like they would actually shift
perspective so that Rick's hand in the
axe were in frame so you start to freak
out a little bit oh my god they're
trying to tell us something he even
sanitizes it here you're gonna need this
in the number 8 he forces Rick to cut
off Karl's left arm or you a southpaw so
you're just sitting there wondering
what's gonna happen like that's the
definition of suspense when they just
hold you in that moment there's no real
action
just everyone [ __ ] their pants so
number seven was the face that negan was
trying to get out of Rick Rick is now
like a scared dog and that's kind of the
way it happened in the comics it sets
off this big arc for Rick where his
personality shifts he becomes this
really weak person and his journey
becomes trying to get back to badass
level Rick but there's this period in
the comics where he's like this scared
dog he almost seems kind of disgusting
even though you can understand like
what's happened to him here he just has
this complete mental breakdown when
negan says he's gonna kill everyone if
he doesn't chop off Karl's arm like a
slice of salami so that's gonna last
even though we saw like the
flash-forward in the trailer for next
week's episode inside he is broken like
at the end of the episode you know
number 6 Maggie wants war we have to get
him we have to go with the fight Rick's
just like no he's not having any of that
there will be no fighting he is now like
a little abused animal who rolls over on
his belly when he gets afraid so my
number 5 though was like the set design
like the weight you know when negan
draws him out in the RV and he has to
jump onto that hanger that they threw
over the side of the overpass which then
starts to bite him as he's falling into
the pile
negan saves him but you know as he's
rolling to get the axe he rolls next to
the head just the whole way they
designed that scene was amazing that was
when I still thought that it was just
gonna be Rick and negan for the entire
episode and it was great you could
actually do an entire episode like that
I feel like we're headed for some Karl
stuff like there's a really awesome Karl
ark when negan debuts in the
if you want to read that obviously it
starts after issue 100 but you can kind
of see like the people that they killed
what that's going to do for the
characters that were close to them like
it's a big thing for Maggie's character
art this is also a big thing for Carl's
character arc and it has to do
specifically with the nican character so
depending on what they do from the
comics we'll talk about that as they go
along but number four Darryl is now
their hostage if you step out of line
I'll cut off pieces of him send it to
yet better yet I'll bring him and make
you do it so that's a big thing making
you do it just like he did with the axe
oh no I'm not gonna cut his arm off I'm
gonna make you do it but the other thing
that made this so much worse not not the
way that they teased you with Darryl
dying because he lashed out when negan
was like anybody that lashes out is dead
so I don't think that they had the guts
to kill Darryl just because he's one of
the most popular characters everybody
would riot but Dwight still has his
compound bow and I feel like even though
I think Dwight's gonna be in a couple
more episodes he will be one of the
first big acts of retribution when they
start taking down saviors eventually
you'll have that amazing moment where
Daryl kills Dwight and takes back his
bow think about how much everyone
cheered when Daryl took his motorcycle
back that was an amazing moment so now
we have the bow to get back that's gonna
be awesome but it's probably not gonna
happen for a while number three was that
dream sequence at the end if you were
confused by that because you're like
okay they're still alive and Glenn has a
child in his lap that was meant to be a
visualization of a thing that would
never happen as negan would had that
voice over where he said you think this
is Sunday dinner no that's not happening
so this moment here isn't something that
actually happened it was a potential
future had they not met negan and that's
another thing to Maggie
almost blamed herself you were out here
because of me although a lot of people
would also blame Rick to because he was
the leader that told them what to do
because of this big situation so really
there's a lot of blame to hand around
but really negan is so terrible they
would have gotten to a moment like that
no matter what they had done but number
two suck my nuts Abraham goes out in
style what a way to go he takes it like
a champ and I hope you were not eating
anything when they panned down in
showed like the viscera just like a pile
of guts in gore which is what you know
number one WTF was the Glen kill just
because it was the comic book moment it
went down exactly like it did in the
comics he had the line of dialogue where
he's trying to speak but he barely can't
his eyes all bugged out you can see here
they made it look almost exactly like it
did on the page so even though they
played a lot of tricks on us with the
way they cut the episode up with all the
commercial breaks and they use the
flashbacks they still did the comic book
thing so just expect more of that this
season a lot of negan moments from the
comics but that are kind of broken up
and told in different ways so the next
big things that are coming are the
kingdom ezekiel shiva the tiger can't
wait to see the tiger in getting a
deeper dive in the Society of the
Savior's in the reign of negan so the
first big arc of this season is going to
be negan exerting control over everyone
like this new life of servitude that
they're entering into but there's all
kinds of stuff that they can do in the
back half I think it's way too soon for
stuff like all-out war if you've read
the comics you have the whispers there's
still so much stuff that they can do but
really now the task at hand is getting
to know the Savior's better all those
characters and then meeting all the
people at the kingdom so let me know in
the comments what was your favorite
moment from the episode and how many of
your predictions came true when it came
to the deaths
I feel like Abraham and Glenn were the
safe picks so most people probably
guessed right the thing about Abraham
the reason why I think they killed him
is one because he's a big dude so negan
probably saw him as a potential threat
that he wanted to neutralize when he had
the chance but also like just from a
writer's perspective in the writers room
he'd gotten to this really Zen state he
was happy he started living his life the
way he thought he should so it was
almost like he'd gotten to this new
level of heaven which means that that's
when you pull the rug out from under him
so the minute a character feels - happy
- safe - powerful that's when they die
so for now I think all the main
characters at least the main characters
maybe not supporting characters but all
the main characters that are still alive
are safe at least for the first half of
the season but get height is gonna be
awesome I'm really happy with the
direction they go I feel like bringing
negan on not only is it gonna crush in
the ratings that's proper
why they renewed the series early
because they're like oh yeah [ __ ] and
all this stuff is gonna crush people are
gonna love this but I feel like it
actually did pay off like I'm really
excited to see what's coming from
Jeffrey Dean Morgan negan character
Jeffrey Dean Morgan was great in the
episode too I feel like he's gonna be a
lot of fun it's a really special actor
that can make you love a person that is
that terrible but I am starting the
weekly Walking Dead giveaway it's a $20
Amazon gift card all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video if there are any
bonus videos that you guys want me to do
just let me know in the comments but it
is gonna be an awesome season I'm gonna
have to go vandalize some stuff with
Lucille here she's a vampire bat she's
so thirsty well you guys wait for my
next video to post oh you can click up
top to learn all about the Deadpool -
drama the reason that director dropped
out and you can click down here for like
a really funny trailer from Ryan
Reynolds on why the Deadpool movie just
crushed so hard earlier this year
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight